before the video starts guys i've come
together with montana 8 to help those
who have lost their sight to see again
just imagine enabling these people in
these countries who are blind who cannot
work and can do nothing to see again may
allah give you guys that clear sight in
the hereafter that you have enabled
people to see in this life inshallah
please donate in the link below
[Music]
assalamu alaikum what happened today
better care to brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys will
inshallah do i condemn the attacks
against
salman rushdie
that's the first question that's usually
asked the muslims do you condemn you yes
you do you condem
yeah
prophet says let's
let's break this down let's look at the
elephant in the room
i want to ask a simple question i asked
this to
cosmic skeptic
yeah the little boy yeah
the same question
and i want to break it down to you guys
so you can understand this phenomena
it's a phenomena that we as muslims and
islam is being accused of being
intolerant against freedom of speech
that we cannot deal with criticism
and islam is so weak that anyone that
criticizes we know we crumble
let's look at this phenomena i want to
ask a simple question
you guys might know and not know in
turkey you know one of its you know
founders or hero should we say
i'm kurdish turk
i know of him
if i was to write a book about
and i was to insult his mom his dad his
daughter his son his grandad if i was to
do this and i saw these books
do you agree with me
that turkey as a
a a um country and the people within
itself within it uh living there do you
think there will be uprisings yes they
would be do you think they'll be upset
yes they'll be do you think a faction of
turkish people would want to come
together
and execute me
yes it's basic human psychology
to be upset to p to a person that you
love
okay good let's move on i'm kurdish
myself um i was involved with certain
political things when i was young my dad
was also my family was deeply and when
abdullah which is one of the leaders of
the pkk um he was um arrested and taken
to turkey and now he's actually an
island
there was people that i knew yes where
we would go to certain protests which
were one of those i didn't attend like i
was too young they went and set their
self on fire let's let's put this into
perspective they put petrol over their
self and they set themselves in fire in
central london this was all over the
news
these people were ready to set their
self i mean
i don't know who you love that much
about the panel to set yourself on fire
it's a whole different different level
now let's put this into perspective if i
was to write a book against abdullah the
the head of the pkk group kurdish group
here
and i was to insult him
and there's a lot of kurds that live in
london a lot of curt
i promise you i promise you i will not
be alive for two weeks
in two weeks i'll be done because it's a
lot of kurdish gangs and mafia et cetera
they would get rid of me like this
now
let me give you another example i'll
give many examples if i was to go to
russia and i was to install putin i
wrote a book about putin yeah you guys
get the point if i was to walk in
russian i said look i'm selling my book
today do you think i will be surprised
if a russian spy or somebody just took a
gun out and went bang shoot me in the
head
the point i'm trying to say is the
following
every individual be the secularist
be it the nationalists
be the religious people
any group that you look at if they have
someone that they love
they would go to levels some mate
condemn it somebody say you know what we
condemn it we condemn it we don't want
violence but we condemn this a small
fraction of them might say you know what
no actually we want this guy killed we
want him beheaded we weren't finished
now why is it
that this phenomena that muslims and
islam is the only religion which study
do you have that has been carried out
cross-culturally around the world that
shows us and tells us that you know what
we found a cross-cultural examination we
went to different nations and different
groups and different colors and
different races
all of them said they have no problem
with being insulted against a person
that they may have loved has been um
attacked and all of them said we would
have no problem we'll be okay with this
no problem carry an insult it will help
you insult it
if this hasn't been carried out why the
double standards in the hypocrisy and
this goes back to salman rushdie
the point is the same
wherever you go
wherever you go you will see the same
results because you're dealing with
human beings and some human beings get
upset and take their frustrating out
frustration out by swearing at the
person that does this some go to the
level of blackmailing not black men
threatening writing letters and some go
down the route of trying to kill the
person themself
why is it different with islam
the question that needs to be asked is
not you condemn it
what is the difference with islam
and muslims
that is the question that i want to ask
and this is the key
question here brown sisters
until you answer that question
don't come to us and dare
to say do you condemn it
and like douglas murray said when the
christian attack happened he what did he
say he said we cannot blame anybody but
the perpetrator okay as a muslim you're
asking me to ask me the question do i do
i um condemn the only one that's
responsible for this attack is that
satan himself
i want to be in line with my dear friend
douglas murray yes who's advocate for
freedom of speech but try to stop all
the muslim speakers from speaking to
universities but hypocrite [ __ ] yeah
fool
that's it that's all i have to say about
the sisters this is the bigger question
and i challenge anybody anyone to come
to speaker's corner and debate me on
this topic of
this phenomena phenomena that i talked
about until then shut your mouth and
don't come and tell us that as muslims
that islam is intolerant come to me and
bring the evidence of this
cross-cultural examination this big
study that was done cross-culturally
around the world around the globe that
everybody was okay all kinds of groups
and races were okay with except muslims
till then shut your mouth uh like my
dear friend says mohammed jab
you're finished
until next time sisters and guess what
oh yeah just to finish on this note
since we're on this topic inshallah
brahmin sisters i am working with
um to help people insha allah see so
basically it's a 70 pound operation uh
which helps people who have cataracts
and other diseases uh with their eyes
inshallah to see again inshallah you
know because obviously some people go
blind and we want inshallah to give them
their eyesight back for some people you
can't but for some people you can with
this operation which is 70 pounds wrong
sisters do check that inshallah